we're asked to solve the equation three
plus the principal square root of 5x
plus 6 is equal to 12 and so the general
strategy to solve this type of equation
is to isolate the radical sign on one
side of the equation and then you can
square it to essentially get the radical
sign to go away but you have to be very
careful there because when you square
radical signs you actually lose the
information that you are taking the
principal square root not the negative
square root or not the plus or minus
square root you're only taking the
positive square root and so when we get
our final answer we do have to check and
make sure that it gels with taking the
principal square root so let's try let's
see what I'm talking about so the first
thing I want to do is I want to isolate
this on one side of the equation the
best way to isolate that is to get rid
of this 3 and the best way to get rid of
the 3 is to subtract 3 from the
left-hand side and of course if I do it
on the left hand side I also have to do
it on the right hand side otherwise I
would lose the ability to say that
they're equal and so the left hand side
right over here simplifies to the
principal square root of 5x plus 6 and
this is equal to 12 minus 3 this is
equal to 9 and now we can square both
sides of this equation so we could
square five the principal square root of
5x plus 6 and we can square nine when
you do this when you do this when you
square this you get 5x 5x plus 6 if you
square the square root of 5x plus 6
you're going to get 5x plus 6 and this
is where we actually lost some
information because we would have also
gotten this if we squared the negative
square root of 5x plus 6 and so that's
why we have to be careful with the
answers we get and actually make sure it
works when the original equation was the
principal square root so we get 5x plus
6 on the left hand side and then on the
right hand side we get 81 and now this
is just a straight-up linear equation we
want to isolate the X terms let's
subtract 6 from both sides subtract 6
from both sides on the left hand side we
have 5x and on the right hand side we
have 75 and then we can divide both
sides by 5 divide both sides by 5 we get
X is equal to let's see X it
fifteen right five times ten is fifty
five times five is 25 this is 75 so we
get X is equal to 15 but we want to we
need to make sure that this actually
works for our original equation maybe
this would have maybe this would have
worked if we were date if this was the
negative square root so we need to make
sure it actually works for the positive
square root for the principal square
root so let's apply it to our original
equation so we get three plus the
principal square root of five times 15
so 75 plus 675 plus six plus six so I
just took five times 15 over here I put
our solution in should be equal to 12 or
we get three plus square root of 75 plus
six is 81 it needs to be equal to 12 and
this is the principal root of 81 so it's
positive nine so it's three plus nine
needs to be equal to 12 which is
absolutely true so we can feel pretty
good about this answer